larry david is the goat and i'll tell
you why i love it the goat i love it
has hundreds of millions of dollars yes
okay
i mean untold untouchable amounts of
money yeah okay this is between seinfeld
and obviously uh curb enthusiasm i'm
sure other things these [ __ ] two of
the greatest sitcoms in the history
of the world i'll even give you that
i'll give you give you that okay
still funny still hilarious still can
write great comedy yep
great comedy oftentimes comes from
inconvenience his comment specifically
yes is the inconveniences that he
endures yes yes he's so wealthy
he can remove all of these
inconveniences true he doesn't have to
go to zancoo chicken he doesn't have to
go to this funeral that funeral he
doesn't have to do any of these things
right but he's so pure and so committed
to the comedy yeah that he's still
putting himself in these situations yes
where he is constantly infuriated and
interrupted and annoyed with life it is
purity he's committed he's a great true
[ __ ] comedian you're gonna put a clip
up right now mark's gonna put that's
absolutely hilarious but do you
understand like i think this is why
comedians when they get successful they
oftentimes become less funny it's go go
you remove all the inconvenience because
what does anybody do when they make
money make life as convenient as
possible i'll move to the suburbs why
it's cheaper it's more convenient it's
easier
in the yard i don't have to talk to
people when we're in miami
i couldn't write a single [ __ ] joke
life was there was the inconveniences
were removed yes we're on a [ __ ]
canal the biggest inconvenience was
the ladies dog on the other side of the
canal sometimes came out the biggest
thing is you're not on the water like
you're not on the on the ocean we're not
in the ocean that is the canal
it's a big inconvenience though to be
honest with you but and so it's like a
city like new york breeds that because
you're constantly in convenience you're
with [ __ ] eight million people it's
like banging in constantly the fact that
larry david can be worth hundreds of
millions of dollars live on a massive
property somewhere like and still create
comedy still like have these story lines
like of course eddie murphy hasn't done
a new special he gets to just live in
his beautiful home hanging out with this
beautiful family what are you doing as
many women as wants you have all the
kids in the world he's too rich come on
he's too rich what are we expecting here
it's true
it's true i'm just saying you got to
give credit show she'll run this clip
right here please all right this is him
uh introducing ariana grande on snl
i'm so excited
ladies and gentlemen ariana
have just said i'm committed to this i'm
going to say the name properly it's also
it's not that hard a [ __ ] name
yeah granny it's just hating starbucks
like coffee and you've said grande
ariana is not crazy yeah it's not like a
super ethnic name i mean she he's just
so old
it's all new to him ariana's such a new
name right here as if he like [ __ ] up
a first pitch yeah
it's a name right like as if he was
going into it going man i'm really gonna
mess up one of the easiest names to
pronounce ever and then it happens the
funniest thing is this is his only shot
it's not like he was doing a 20-minute
monologue and then had to get the name
it's like all right you got five seconds
point camera
is a [ __ ] teleprompter you got it
buddy here we go
and now ariana grande has to come out
knowing that's what happened ladies and
gentlemen
no the reaction seemed too genuine he
was genuine it seemed
he was just like come on
he's also so rich and famous and
successful that this is not gonna last
these things yeah yeah yeah anybody else
would be a [ __ ] i messed my moment i
know oh my god ariana grande he doesn't
have a [ __ ] firearm he's mad at him
yeah i'm rich i don't care he's so lucky
that his whole brand is like the guy
that does dumb [ __ ] i mean so like any
time he does something i flubbed a line
i introduced someone wrong and they go
oh it's larry dude that's brilliant it's
like brand yourself around
a version of you that you can maintain
brand yourselves is the cool guy like
[ __ ] you guys
you gotta hold on to that forever this
is what akash has had to endure his
whole life
perfect everyone looks at him and
they're like this guy this is my
struggle epitome of cool like it's my
struggle so i had to move out of the
house where people think i'm [ __ ] i mean
but like travis scott puts on a [ __ ]
batman uniform they're like what a loser
and he's like i just want to wear my
jacket i just thought you guys would
think it's cool i'm gonna wear my batman
costume so true the pressure of being
the cool guy it's like maybe that's why
tom cruise is in [ __ ] scientology
it's he's living up to being the
superhero yeah the guy who gets the girl
who says the witty line who saves the
[ __ ] day in every single movie and
then in real life
he's five six
[Laughter]
right like every short [ __ ]
five six one a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy what a
shrimp at least you know that you
shouldn't join scientology if you're
like okay they couldn't fix that five
six you be a respectable height like
five seven you did it oh that's right
you're five seven yeah yeah oh yeah do
you still talk yeah jesus
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
i gotta tell y'all about incognity okay
thousands of companies are collecting
aggregating and trading your personal
data without you knowing anything about
it you have the right
to request data brokers to delete what
information they have about you and
protect your privacy the bad news is it
would take you years to do it manually
but incognito can do the messy work for
you automatically incognit helps you
protect your privacy and take your
personal data off the market by reaching
out to data brokers on your behalf and
requesting your personal data removal
and dealing with their objections i'm
telling you companies often have your
full name email home address they know
your shopping habits they got your
social security number there are things
that you do not want out there for your
safety and just for your personal
privacy that's yours it should stay
yours i'm telling you your information
is out there and you don't even know it
let's say you subscribe to a free
newsletter shortly after you're probably
getting inundated with a lot of spam
that's because they sold your [ __ ] they
sold your [ __ ] to some other company so
they could spam your damn email i mean
someone you don't know found out your
home address phone number and personal
information where the hell you think
they found it out it's available to them
if they know where to look for it and
you can wipe that off the internet so
what we're gonna do right now is the
first 100 people to use the code schultz
at the link below are going to get 20
off of incognito protect your privacy
today go to incognit.com
schultz and use the code schultz to take
your personal data off the markets now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
clip you can watch the full episode and
join the [ __ ] army at patreon.com
dude the uh i i don't know i just i
wonder if every person that you met
expected you to be a [ __ ] superhero
because there was a time in america
where like they didn't know actors were
short
yeah
yeah yeah yeah kind of like your
generation is like a myth yeah you found
out you're like wait really yes the guy
from mission impossible short yes even
that was a big thing they were talking
about because that's not cruz there's no
way everybody's seeing you and going
like oh my god he's so short they're
whispering because they can't [ __ ]
believe it because you're propped up on
an apple box the entire time you're
shooting yeah so you're a letdown yeah
off rip me and you don't even look short
again talking about the offer this is a
real thing they didn't want to cast
pacino because you started watching that
fine so much fun it's so great it's it's
so fun
i didn't i interrupted you
they they keep making a big deal about
how short pacino is he's so little he's
so little if you watch that and you
don't know that you don't know he's
short you can't tell yeah just the way
they frame everything told people it's
like it's weird yeah yeah but uh anyway
talk about the show no uh
it is
what ocean's 11 is for me yeah
yeah it's a quirky group of misfits yeah
that are coming together to solve an
unsolvable problem yes and
what's even better about this is that
it's real
yeah it's not like
the most amazing thing i've ever seen it
is the most fun yes it's not breaking
bad yes ocean's eleven is a great
comparison it's ocean's eleven for tv
yeah it's just fun but it's based on a
real story
so every scene is heightened because
you're like oh my god this really
happened he was with a mobster yeah and
he put together the script and there's
no [ __ ] papers in there yeah like 100
percent
it's all capers yeah trying to pull off
everything and like pissing people off
it's just constantly pulling it all
together and problem solving it was like
what made entourage really great to be
honest remember when like entourage was
just like problem solving there's a
massive problem the group has to come
together yes and use their unique
talents in order to solve 100 and yeah
uh you were like big on it so i was like
okay i gotta give this thing a shot and
i found myself like i know the outcome
yeah yeah the whole thing is like are
they gonna make the godfather yeah and
it's like
yeah
yeah you're like but i'm still into it
it's like pastor of the christ i'm like
i think he might make it but it's way
like it's
when you know what's going to happen
because then you're like it's there's no
way that they're going to build that's
what i was saying i was like how the
[ __ ] did they figure this out [ __ ] that
that's interesting that's a different
dynamic like you know that it did so
they can exaggerate how difficult it is
it's a very youtube thing like every
youtube video is like like every mystery
beasts videos i did this and you're like
there's no way he can make a chocolate
and then you start watching and you're
like
and then but you're committed to because
you because you already know what's
gonna happen
i spent 100 days underground you're like
it's not like i try this one hundreds
you're starving in day 12. you're like
[ __ ] go the other day
exactly yeah every episode ends with
like how the [ __ ] did you get out of
this yeah and then you watch the next
episode they got out and then another
thing pops up yeah dude it also reminded
me just like talk about go watch it so
we can all talk about it like actually
break down episodes like everybody who's
listening do that but please it reminds
me just it's a reminder that so this is
again widely considered the greatest
movie of all time
and it reminds the godfathers and it
reminds you these great things
often seem like a bunch of [ __ ] you have
to overcome to get there yeah you know
what i mean even you're special i'm sure
there was i know i've seen hundreds of
moments when they were like this whole
thing's gonna fall apart everything all
the money were [ __ ] and then you just
overcome these things and more often
than not it ends up working out and
sometimes the greatest things come from
that mayhem oh for sure and that's a
comforting thing whenever i'm like i
always feel like whenever there's a show
where that is important but [ __ ] is
going crazy the whole time beforehand i
weirdly feel a sense of calm because i'm
like yo if i look back in my life so
many times this everything just comes
together when it needs to when i crashed
my car on the way to the special watch
party
i'm not even crashing all jokes aside i
didn't actually crash it with you back
into a thing that you there was already
there but all jokes aside you'd be like
i didn't even back in
i could see it yeah okay
i sighed it in like i saw it because the
crash sounds like you're a victim in a
way you know the name whereas this is
just pure negligence and stupidity of my
own negligence
so embarrassing i said i i can't even
hit up the insurance company because
they're gonna be what's happened i'm
gonna be like i was driving
i was driving and i'm not good at that
blame your girl yes yeah yeah yeah
that's a great point
dude
talking about that
your car is destroyed oh yeah oh [ __ ]
that was crazy did you blame your life
yeah yeah yeah yeah what happened dude
it's [ __ ] i don't know i literally in
the middle of the night he wasn't coming
out she's like let me try something else
just line the pregnant jews up
they called her go to birth she's like i
can't make it she delivers babies yeah
in an untraditional way yes come on
which is actually the most traditional
way if you think what is that driving a
car into them
i missed that part
that's how she messed up the bumper
that's a traditional abortion buddy come
on
dude let's think about it past that
discussion that was last week's fake
care about oh my bad yeah america's
moved on what are we on now hi we're on
the bumpers bunkers are a big deal my
car got [ __ ] up and the only way that
i could get the money back is if i get
the video footage but i can't get the
video footage unless a police officer
goes to the building so literally i was
googling police officer outfits to rent
from africa
i swear to god i was this close from
dressing as a cop and being like hello
i'm the cop
i need
i need the footage for my car or their
car they got hit and they're gonna be
like what and why you have a ponytail
and be like well it's we're at different
precincts it's uh it's very uh it's
gonna think a stripper walked in
that's where we had to rent it from it's
from a stripper a website i think and
then i'm gonna tear away that in the
army
i had a buddy of mine reach out and then
connected you to another buddy who was
actually from that precinct yeah no he
was from like another one but like a
block or like a county over something
and they basically said
yeah it's out of our jurisdiction it's a
whole hassle yeah we're good so i'm like
calling up the lady i'm like trying to
i'm trying to finesse so we'll see
but it's crazy it's an inconvenient
amount of money my deductible is like
300 bucks so i'm like am i willing to
put in the work
to pay like basically i'm saving the car
could be ruined though completely i
didn't get totaled oh yeah yeah
dangerous don't pay the money
yeah but i'm like even if it gets
totaled they'll pay you for it it's the
principle it's the principal okay i've
lost how do i know how do i know it's
not the same guy that hit me on my bike
what if it's that guy he's just a menace
destroying my life around new york city
how do i know it's not him and i let him
free i literally catch and release and
now he [ __ ] got my car 300 deductible
yeah that's nothing so first of all who
pays deductibles
stop i have to wait what who who says
you have to you can't walk to the auto
body shop and the geico the [ __ ]
british lizard said i have to pay that
amount of money if they are telling you
that then you go to the auto body shop
and say hey buddy
i'm not gonna pay this
you're gonna find you're going to find
some damage is the offer what the [ __ ]
are you talking about are you miles
teller what do you mean you guys pay
deductibles yes yes
this is how the world goes around the
only reason you get away with it is
because good samaritans like us pay
you're taking advantage of these systems
if nobody paid the company wouldn't make
any [ __ ] money um you don't don't
don't do my thing
don't don't you do my thing literally
you were like why did we get kicked out
of every country that's it pay the
deductible please dove no no no no
don't worry i'll uh i'll tell you how to
not pay your deductible why don't you
tell everybody that's listening right
now dude okay fine yeah oh god fine it
might be hard but fine no but come on
you go to an auto body shop you know you
have a deductible you're going to tell
them yo you want me to come to this auto
body shop or the one down the block
you're going to find enough damage that
you're going to report to the insurance
company
extra 300 damage i mean 300 is such a
small amount if it was a thousand dollar
deductible 2 000 i'd be like okay how
are they going to do that well 300 keep
going
come on they know these insurance
adjusters they're going to want your
business and they're going to say yeah
you don't need to pay so they will over
char they'll over if you have five
thousand dollars worth of damage double
say hey if you want my business say
there's fifty three hundred dollars
worth of damage saying what to say my
check i keep that three hundred dollars
profit and then i broke even on i'm not
saying what to say i'm just saying you
go in there and say hey you say there's
more damage they get paid for the more
damage and then you get that three
hundred dollars back okay so i'll walk
in i'd be like oh it'd be a shame if
something happened to my car
i break the window no no no no no
you don't even need to break anything
else yeah that just adds actual damage
that you actually have to pay for god
you're white bro
you're really [ __ ] white dude see
this is the problem it looks like uh
something is a real shame huh if if this
car was totaled well they might think
you're from the insurance though like oh
yeah he kind of seems like he's
incognito well no i was thinking like he
looks like a top uniform on then you
just look like like insurance adjusters
don't wear cop uniforms
no i don't what's your logic you do i
don't know i'm trying to get my car
fixed okay
no one's going to be out of body
shopping tell me to give them a shout
out there's a there's a great one down
the block
that is my thing i shout out small
businesses tony's automotive in brooklyn
check them out hey that's where i talk
it's tesla good guys over at tony's okay
we love tony's
yeah [ __ ] that place dude what what's
wrong with that
oh yeah sorry they don't work on your
computer car okay they work on real to
ensure i can muscle i paid them cash
for the damage that mark did to my
attention oh i had a [ __ ]
all-american oh nissan yeah a nissan an
all-american nissan yeah exactly come on
dude see this is yeah yeah the insurance
hustle is
i had my parents studio got uh robbed
once
when uh we were kids my dad's like uh
mark he's just the honest you know super
guy what did they steal from a dance
studio
[Laughter]
no no they stole all the uh the audio
equipment okay there was you know like
speakers yeah whatever cd players and
all that kind of [ __ ] and well they sell
half of it they took half of it and the
uh
my dad calls the cops and the cops come
in and they look around they go ah man
it's a shame they took all the uh the
audio equipment and my dad goes uh
actually we got pretty lucky he only
took half of it he goes
the real shame they took all the audio
quickly bro that's insurance adjuster
this is the tops this is the cops
basically going buddy you're too stupid
to know how to play the system you need
that kind of help this happens to me
literally all the time where people are
like oh you're like a nice dumb guy yeah
so like we're gonna hook you up so
literally alicia okay as like a gift to
me she like got me a ring i was like
dude i want to get like a [ __ ] sick
pinky ring she's like all right cool i
got it for you she literally gives it to
me i would go to the we go like a me
jury or something it's like not even an
expensive ring but we go in there i get
it i take it outside i'm about to put on
my finger i drop it on the ground within
like two minutes of leaving the place i
pick it up and it's got a huge like den
and a scuff all on the side and i was
like oh my god like the second we walk
out the store like it could not have
been closer to the time i gave the guy
my [ __ ] card i bought my own gift and
then
literally dude
and then and then went back inside and i
walk in and i'm talking to dude the guy
was like just chatting up while i was in
there i was like hey ben i look i
dropped my ring outside like the second
i walked out there
i what do i do and he was like well
don't say that first off he's like
immediately don't say that um i'm gonna
put you in with like one of our like
jewelry adjusters and just say that you
open the box and it was scuffed and i
was like perfect yeah like that's fine
so i go to the lady and she's like she's
like oh what's this she was like oh the
size is a little weird and there's like
a weird scuff on it and she opens it up
and for like legit 10 minutes she's like
that's so weird
i've never seen something like this ever
on any of our pieces of jewelry like
calls like her manager and like the boss
like the [ __ ] mystery jewelry is
looking at it and they got like the
monocle [ __ ] and they're like examined
they're like yeah it's really really
strange we've never seen this yeah and
this just was like this when you opened
it and i was i'm like sweating and i
feel so guilty like [ __ ] lying to
these people and i hate that the guy
told me like oh yeah just don't bring it
up you'll be fine and you can't snitch
on him because he can get fired i know
and so he forced me into a lie i didn't
expect to have to lie i thought that
they would be like you didn't expect to
have to commit to the lie yeah exactly i
thought they would look at it and be
like oh yeah it's fine we'll swap them
out this happens all the time and he
just forced me to lie so i'm literally
sweating looking at him and he's like
you're doing great
keep it up come on just roll with it and
then eventually they're like oh yeah
you're fine and then gave me the new
ring and i just was walked out there
just like
so what happens after that do you feel
like is that the guilt of watching is
catholic guilt real like that i mean i
mean this sincerely he's never killed
the guild wearing it wait what you don't
wear it no well that's the guilt is that
my mom thinks i'm gay because i have a
pinky ring
i can't double kill exactly it's like
twice the kill what a nightmare dude
it's a [ __ ] catch 69 but yeah i'm
like i don't want to walk around
i'm not gonna wear pinker on like a
casual day i feel like that's like a
special event